Você viu a reportagem do Fantástico que
está assustando todo mundo sobre
vitaminas? Pois é, parece que agora a
vitamina é o maior vilão. Mas será que é
isso mesmo? Olha só o que eu descobri
analisando os casos. A matéria fala de
três pacientes graves, não é? Mas veja
bem, a primeira tomou soro da imunidade
sem exame. A segunda teve reações a
injeções e implantes hormonais. Tem nada
a ver com o assunto. Olha só, reação
adversa. pode acontecer com qualquer
substância, até com de pirona. E o
terceiro caso, um profissional
prescrevendo oito vitaminas em dos
inadequadas. Isso não é problema da
vitamina, é problema de quem está
aplicando, que não deve ter conhecimento
e experiências suficientes. Sabe o que
mais me incomoda? A Anvisa registrou 240
notificações de problemas com
suplementos no ano passado. 240? Parece
muito, não é? Mas você sabia que só de
intoxicação por paracetamol temos mais
de 1000 casos graves por ano no Brasil e
por dipirona mais de 500. E olha só que
paracetamol e dipirona são só dois entre
vários analgésicos e antiinflamatórios
problemáticos. E ninguém faz reportagem
bombástica sobre isso. Por que será?
Será que vocês sinceramente pensam que
essa reportagem veio assim
aleatoriamente? Será que isso foi uma
coisa assim por acaso ou tem alguém por
trás financiando esse tipo de
reportagem? Olha, vou ser bem direto com
você. Suplemento não é bala de goma, mas
também não é veneno. O problema real é
esse, gente preparo prescrevendo ou zero
acompanhamento médico. É como dar uma
Ferrari para quem não sabe dirigir e
depois culpar o carro pelo acidente.
Agora, deixa te contar o que o
Fantástico não falou. Vitamina C
intravenosa em dose de 20 a 50 g. Não é
20 mg, estou falando de 20 a 50 g. Está
sendo utilizado já há muitos anos como
tratamento adjuvante do câncer.
Amplifica efeito da quimioterapia,
melhor a qualidade de vida. Também pode
dobrar a sobrevida em câncer de
pâncreas. Estudos publicados na Science
no Journal of Clinical Oncology. Não é
achismo, é ciência. Vitamina B de bola 3
em dose de 3 g por dia na forma de
exnicotinato,
aprovado pela FD americana para reduzir
colesterol em 25%. E olha que
interessante, estudos mostram que B3
pode ser usado no tratamento da
esquizofrenia publicado no Psychological
Medicine. B2 na dose de 400 mg, previne
em xaqueca, recomendação oficial da
Sociedade Canadense de Cefaleia. reduz
enxaquecas em até 59% dos pacientes.
Vitamina D em dose 10.000 ou mais ao
dia, usado no tratamento de esclerose
múltipla, artrite, reumatoide, psoríase.
B1 ou tiamina em doses altas, protege
contra os e Paxon. E a benfotiamina, uma
forma especial de vitamina B1, está em
testes promissores para os Heimer e já
mostrou melhorar em 77%
os sintomas motores do Paxon inicial.
Mau profissional existe em qualquer
área. Tem médico ruim, tem. Tem médico
despreparado fazendo besteira, também
tem. Mas daí a demonizar as vitaminas é
um salto grande demais. Você está vendo
alguém aí demonizando o uso errado de
antiinflamatório e antibiótico. Tem
reportagem sobre isso no Fantástico.
Você já foi numa fila de transplante
renal para perguntar qual é uma das
causas mais comuns defensa renal? Eu
preciso dizer que é o uso errado de
fármacos. muitos vendidos sem receita.
Cadê a reportagem do Fantástico sobre
isso? A verdade é essa. Suplementação
precisa ser individualizada, precisa de
exame antes, durante e depois. Veja bem,
vitaminas em dose terapêuticas são
verdadeiros fármacos precisos de
indicação precisa, exame de monitoração,
acompanhamento médico rigoroso, precisa
da dose certa, pro tempo certo, pra
pessoa certa. Sem isso, qualquer coisa
vira problema. até água em excesso pode
matar. Então, antes de jogar os seus
suplementos no lixo por causa dessa
reportagem, pense nisso. O problema não
é a ferramenta, é quem usa ela sem
conhecimento. E me conta, você já parou
para questionar quantos remédios você
toma sem necessidade real? Você já
pesquisou quantas pessoas estão com
falência hepática por polifarmácia?
Porque essa discussão Fantástico não
traz e nem vai trazer. Yeah.